(orgue et chant)
- C'était la dernière répétition
de la chorale qui vaer à la mese
dans la capitale albertaine.
En tout, c'est plus de
65 choristes provenantde difféds
et chorales de l'Alberta
qui vont chanter devant
près de 70 000 personnesmardi a.
Pour la coordonnat
de la chorale, la musique est
inévitable pour avancer enversé.
KAREN KOESTER,
coordonnatrice de la chorale
- Pour moi, c'est que la musique
peut gué
tous les gens qui sont humains
que la musique guérit.rit.rit.
Et donc, c'est notre...
Nous espérons que
que nous chanteront à la messe
sera une guérison,
de réconciliation
en espri
- Les choristes vont chanter
en en grec, cri, latin,
français, mais majoritairement
(chant)
Catherine Kubash e
franco-albertaine et choriste
professipuis près de
30 ans. Pour elle, chanter
lors de la messe papale un honn.
CATHERINE KUBASH,
soprano dans la chorale
- Si c'est quelque chose
vers une réconciliation pour
les peup ont besoin
et c'est non seulement
les peuples autochtones, mai so.
Si chanter dans une chorale
puisse aider à développer
une réconciliation,
On ne peut pas dire non
n reçoit l'invitation.
- La chorale chantera
lors de la messe p lieu à 10 h e
du Commonwealth d'Edmonton,
le mardi le 26 juillet.
À tous ceux qui ne possèdent pas
visionner la célébration
en direces
les plateformes de Radio-Canada.
Ici Ind